If x plus 1 is greater than or equal to
9, or negative 2x is greater than 10,
how would you go about finding
the solution set for x?
This is called a compound inequality.
A compound inequality
consists of two inequalities
connected by either the word or,
or the word and.
If the word or is used, that means that
any value of the variable that makes
either inequality true
is in the solution set.
So getting back to this problem
x + 1 is greater than or
equal to 9 simplifies to x is
greater than or equal to 8.
And this simplifies to x is less than 5.
And because this is an or
compound inequality,
any value of the variable that
makes x is greater than or
equal to 8 or x is less than 5
true is in the solution set.
x is greater than or equal to 8 will
look like this, with a closed circle
at 8 and the line extending to infinity,
positive infinity on the right.
And with an open circle over the 5 and
the arrow pointing towards
negative infinity.
So both x is less than 5 and
x is greater than or
equal to 8 are part of the solution set.